.
THE MALE ALLIGATORS.
>> NOT GOOD WHEN THE HORMONES
START RAGING.
>>> TURNING NOW TO A NEW NETFLIX
FILM THAT EXAMINES THE U.S.
JUSTICE SYSTEM THROUGH THE EYES
OF A BLACK TEENAGER.
IT'S CALLED "MONSTER."
IT STARS ACTOR KELVIN HARRISON
JR., REMEMBER HIS NAME.
HE PLAYS 17-YEAR-OLD STEVE
HARMON, AN ASPIRING FILMMAKER,
WHO FINDS HIMSELF ON TRIAL
CHARGED WITH FELONY MURDER FOR A
ROBBERY GONE WRONG.
IT'S A FILM ADAPTATION OF WALTER
DEAN MYERS' AWARD WINNING NOVEL
OF THE SAME NAME.
IN THIS CLIP, HARMON'S MOTHER,
PLAYED BY JENNIFER HUDSON,
VISITS HIM IN PRISON.
>> ALREADY MISSED A LOT.
>> I KNOW.
>> PEOPLE COME BACK FROM THESE
TYPE OF SITUATIONS.
THEY MAKE IT THROUGH IT, AND
THEY DON'T LOOK BACK.
THIS DOESN'T CHANGE WHO YOU ARE.
YOU UNDERSTAND ME?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU CAN STILL GO TO FILM
SCHOOL.
YOU CAN STILL DO GREAT THINGS.
>> YEAH.
YEAH, I CAN.
>> YEAH, YOU CAN.
YOU CAN ALWAYS COUNT ON MOM.
TANYA LEWIS LEE IS ONE OF THE
PRODUCERS AND KELVIN HARRISON
JR. JOIN US FOR AN INTERVIEW
YOU'LL SEE FIRST ON "CBS THIS
MORNING."
THE NAME OF OUR SHOW HASN'T
CHANGED.
WE WELCOME YOU BOTH.
KELVIN, LET ME SAY THIS -- YOUR
PERFORMANCE IS KNOCKOUT.
BRAVO, BRAVO, BRAVO TO YOU.
STAND BY FOR JUST A SECOND
BECAUSE TANYA, I WANT TO START
WITH YOU, MISS TANYA LEWIS LEE.
THIS IS REALLY YOUR BABY.
YOU HAVE BEEN -- BEEN TRYING TO
GET THERE PROJECT TO -- IN FRONT
OF THE AUDIENCE FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
YOU READ THE BAOOK IN 1999.
IT GOT RAVE REVIEWS AT SUNDANCE.
THEN THE PANDEMIC HIT, AND
FINALLY YOU GET IT TO NETFLIX.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT TO
US BECAUSE I WATCHED IT, AND I'M
STILL HAUNTED BY WHAT I SAW ON
THE SCREEN.
WHY WAS THIS SO IMPORTANT TO
YOU?
>> WELL, THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
THIS MORNING.
I THINK THAT WALTER DEANYERS
JUST WROTE AN AMAZING NOVEL THAT
ESSENTIALLY IS A FABLE ABOUT
BEING CAREFUL ABOUT WHO YOU
ASSOCIATE WITH.
IT'S ALSO A STORY ABOUT THE OVER
INCARCERATION OF OUR YOUTH.
DOES THE PUNISHMENT FIT THE
CRIME?
>> YEAH.
>> DID HE OR DID HE DO THIS OR
DOES THE PUNISHMENT FIT THE
CRIME?
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME THAT
WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH OUR
YOUTH.
>> THAT'S THE THING.
DOES THE PUNISHMENT FIT THE
CRIME?
AND DID HE DO IT WAS A QUESTION
THAT KEPT ME AT THE EDGE OF MY
BED AS I WAS WATCHING IT.
KELVIN, LET ME TALK TO YOU
BECAUSE AT ONE POINT IN THE
MOVIE, YOUR OWN ATTORNEY SAYS,
"THE JURY HAS DECIDED THAT
YOU'RE GUILTY BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOUNG AND YOU'RE BLACK AND
YOU'RE ON TRIAL.
WHEN MORE DO THEY NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT YOU?"
SHE SAID, "OUR JOB IS TO SHOW
THEM THAT YOU'RE A HUMAN BEING,"
AND YOUR CHARACTER SAYS, "I AM A
HUMAN BEING."
I WANT TO KNOW FROM YOU, DID
THIS MOVIE AFFECT YOU OR MAKE
YOU RETHINK SOME THINGS IN YOUR
OWN LIFE?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, LIKE STEVE, I
GREW UP IN A PRIVATE -- I WENT
TO A PRIVATE SCHOOL.
>> YOUR CHARACTER STEVE HARMON,
YES.
>> YES, STEVE HARMON.
AND I GUESS STEPPING INTO LIGHT,
OFTENTIMES I'M THINKING AM I AN
ANOMALY, AM I NOT -- AM I
EXEMPT.
I GUESS I'M NOT.
AND I THINK GOING THROUGH LIFE,
I'VE HAD TO KIND OF RE-EVALUATE
HOW I INTERACT WITH PEOPLE, HOW
I INTERACT WITH MYSELF, AND
REMEMBER TO NOT COMPROMISE MY
TRUTH IN THE PROCESS.
SO I KIND OF DID THAT THROUGH
THE MOVIE IN REAL TIME.
>> TANYA, IT'S ANTHONY.
GAYLE MENTIONED THAT YOU
ACTUALLY FILMED THIS BACK IN
2017.
IT WENT TO SUNDANCE IN 2018.
IT'S FINALLY OUT IN 2021.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE REALIZE HOW
MUCH WORK GOES INTO GETTING A
FILM OUT TO AN AUDIENCE.
WHAT'S IT LIKE TO HAVE TO HAVE
PATIENCE FOR THAT, AND HOW DOES
IT FEEL TO FINALLY HAVE AN
AUDIENCE?
>> TANYA'S RELENTLESS IT SEEMS
WHEN IT'S SOMETHING SHE BELIEVES
IN.
YEAH.
>> WELL, I WILL TELL YOU THE
JOURNEY STARTED LONG BEFORE
2017, AS WELL.
YOU KNOW, MY PRODUCING PARTNER,
NICKY SILVER, AND I OPTIONED
THIS BOOK BACK IN 2005 ACTUALLY.
HAD TH RIGHTS, LOST THE RIGHTS,
GOT THEM BACK.
AND IT IS A LOT OF WORK.
IT'S A LOT OF PUTTING A LOT OF
PIECES TOGETHER.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THOSE PIECES
WAS BRINGING JOHN LEGEND ON TO
WRITE AN AMAZING SONG BUT ALSO
BE A PARTNER BECAUSE HE CARES
ABOUT THE ISSUES.
IT'S ABOUT BRINGING THE RIGHT
DIRECTOR ON.
WHEN WE BROUGHT ON ANTHONY
MANLER, A DIRECTOR WHO -- THIS
IS HIS FIRST FEATURE FILM, BUT
HE IS A MUSIC VIDEO DIRECTOR.
THE STORY IS REALLY STEVE'S
STORY, SO WE WANTED ANTHONY TO
HAVE THAT -- GIVEN US THAT STYLE
AND'S THREAT TAKE THAT HE BRINGS
TO HIS VIDEOS TO OUR FILM.
IT'S ABOUT BRINGING THE REST OF
THE CAST, FINDING KELVIN AND THE
REST OF THE CAST.
IT HAS BEEN A LONG, HARD JOURNEY
FOR US, BUT WE GOT HERE.
WE GOT INTO NETFLIX, AND WE'RE
THRILLED THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE IT.
>> YES.
>> KELVIN, IT'S TONY HERE.
I'M CURIOUS -- TALKED ABOUT HOW
THE FILM CHANGED YOU.
I'M CURIOUS, WHAT DO YOU HOPE
THAT AUDIENCES GET OUT OF IT?
AND IS THERE ANY PART OF YOU
THAT THINKS THERE'S SOMETHING
FORTUNATE TO THE FACT THAT IT
WAS STHOT IN 2017 BUT IS COMING
OUT TODAY?
>> YEAH.
I FEEL LIKE, YOU KNOW, FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE, I JUST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KIND OF LIKE
MAINTAIN YOUR YOUTH AND NOT
NECESSARILY BE AFRAID TO BE
CURIOUS.
I THINK ULTIMATELY THAT'S HOW
STEVE FEELS.
HE'S LIKE, I'M ON TRIAL FOR JUST
BEING CURIOUS ABOUT MY LIFE AND
THE STORY AND WHO I AM.
AND THAT'S NOT A CRIME.
I THINK LOOKING AT EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING NOW, IT'S JUST
WE REALLY NEED THIS REASSURANCE
OF NOT BEING GAS LIT OR
BRAINWASHED BY DIGESTING SO MUCH
MEDIA AND SO MUCH HATE AND
CRIME, SO MUCH ABUSE AND DEATH.
AND JUST KIND OF SEE OUR
HUMANITY AGAIN FOR WHAT IT
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE.
>> THAT'S WHAT STRUCK ME,
KELVIN, IS THAT YOU GET TO SEE
THE HUMANITY OF THIS FAMILY,
NUMBER ONE.
YOU'VE GOT A LITTLE BROTHER IN
THE SCENE, AND HE WANTS TO BE A
SUPERHERO.
HE GOES, "WHY CAN'T I JUST BE
YOUR BIG BROTHER?"
THERE ARE SWEET, TOUCHING
MOMENTS THAT TOUCH ON HUMANITY.
TANYA, BACK TO YOU FOR A SECOND.
THE CAST THAT YOU GOT, A$AP
ROCKY, JEFFREY WRIGHT, JENNIFER
HUDSON, NAZ, HOW DID YOU PULL A
CAST LIKE THAT TOGETHER?
> WELL, AGAIN, I HAVE TO SAY
WALTER DEAN MYERS.
I THINK THE NOVEL ITSELF WAS
JUST SUCH A GALVANIZING PIECE OF
WORK THAT EVERYONE WANTED TO
COME TO WORK ON IT.
A$AP ROCKY SAID IT'S ONE OF THE
BOOKS THAT HE READ IN HIGH
SCHOOL THAT HE LOVED.
HE WAS HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE.
SO YOU KNOW, I THINK WE HAD
GREAT -- GREAT SUBJECT MATTER,
AND SO ARTISTS WANT TO PLAY IN
GOOD WORK.
I WILL SAY, I HOPE KELVIN HAS A
CAREER AS LONG AS NORMAN LLOYD
BECAUSE HE'S SUCH A GREAT ACTOR.
>> YES.
OH, YEAH.
BEAUTIFULLY SAID, AND SO TRUE.
KELVIN, I KNOW WE'VE GOT TO GO
QUICKLY, BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU HUNG OUT WITH TANYA AND
SPIKE'S KIDS TO GET THE LAY OF
THE LAND RUNNING AROUND IN NEW
YORK.
I'M THINKING THAT'S A GREAT TOUR
GUIDE TO HAVE.
JACKSON AND SATCHEL.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN FROM THEM?
>> THEY'RE INCREDIBLE.
THEY'RE SO SMART AND SO FUN.
AND LIKE I -- THERE'S SO MUCH
MUSIC I HADN'T HEARD FROM LIKE
THE STUFF THAT THEY LISTEN TO,
FROM LIKE FRANK OCEAN AND JUST
LIKE -- I LEARNED THE SLANG, I
LEARNED THAT, AND I DON'T KNOW
--
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL, BRAVO TO YOU BOTH.
WELL DONE, GUYS.
WELL DONE.
TANYA LEWIS LEE, THANK YOU.
KELVIN HARRISON, MAY YOU HAVE A